їх цінності нам не близькі ви знаєте я
би дуже хотів повернутися на війну Я
вважаю що Не всі чоловіки На війні є
ефективними і потрібні там була у нас
іншого озброєння була би в рази менше
втрат Росія - це такий чиряк на на
планеті які вибухне
і я думаю я надіюсь що він вибухне через
те що він пішов на Україну наслідки
нашого програшу це війна в Європі
вітаємо всі Дякую що знайшли сили
поговорити сьогодні з нами Як я себе
почуваєте
гірше але тепер можу сказати що велика
краще ви якось писали що ви щасливі що
живий
але все що у вас дуже серйозно травма
наскільки вона вам зараз обмежує ваш
життя впала якість життя це запахи є
взагалі не чую і мені сказали вчора що
можливо ще ніколи не буде відчувати це
суттєво змінює всю картину тому що для
мене запах дуже важливий а тут нерв
якийсь іде і цей нерв фактично якось
пошкоджено і головні болі вони знаєте
так
інколи вони мотивують цю справді біль -
це гарна історія
для роботи з собою вона дуже цікава
насправді і в принципі я не скажу що в
мене обмеження Ну і відчуває якийсь
певні обмеження Я ще не жив своїм життям
я не сів за своє кермо автомобіля я був
в себе вдома вона не щупав свої речі щоб
усвідомити що сталось хоча загалом да
воно неприємною воно тут пече весь час і
я розумію що вони залишаються наче такі
знаєте відчуття що тут щось холодне
лежить і перші тижні я весь час надіявся
що воно ось-ось зникне але зараз вже
пройшов час і дякуючи психологи рідним
друзям Я швидко усвідомлюю Що сталось
ця реальність вона нова цікава не знаю
чи життя яке буде далі
краще за смерть яка могла бути Але я
впевнений по моєму відчуттю Що те що я
живий зараз і те що я можу бачити себе в
своїх рідних
воно варто від того щоби
мучитись навіть якщо далі будуть болі
якісь ви проходите процес реабілітації А
скільки вас уже було операцій ну була
одна велика колись ставили титанові
пластину була одна маленька Коли
викачувала повітря яке з'явилось в
голові
і планується ще це все було від уламку
Так це був уламок від
міни яка
дивно чином там опинилась і вона
вибухнула і мама долетів мені в голову А
ви в інтерв'ю телебачення сказали що ви
би дуже хотіли мати знову Виходи зі
своїм побратимом Сашею Тобто це означає
що ви би хотіли повернутися знову на ви
знаєте я би дуже хотів повернутися на
війну
з за своїм побратимами з Сашою
бо це знаєте такий момент
[музика]
поки триває війна це відчуття
приналежності до чогось великого і
прекрасного як до ЗСУ воно не залишає
тебе і ти розумієш що це єдине місце де
ти себе відчуваєш в цей час в цьому
моменті відчуваєш себе ефективним
є чесно кажучи дуже хочеться повернути
своє здоров'я для того щоб бути
достатньо сильним аби мати можливість
всю ту
ті розчарування коли ти бачиш біль людей
для того щоб хтось загинув щоб це все
якось перевести в якісь більш дієве
русло оскільки ви знаєте що бізнесом
займатися під час війни складніше
складно
і таким чином допомагати свою правильно
Але я розумію що вони ще є здоров'я буду
там Тобто це не відчуття боргу а це
більше як враження що найбільш дієве
місце зараз в Україні - це збройні сили
України Так я думаю що борг везете в
першу чергу це мова про захист такої
політичної системи в країні яка нам
ближча яку ми обирали ми обирали Русю ми
набрали росіян в Україні ми їх цінності
нам не близькі вони
не створюють ну тобто в мене немає
бажання жити в Росії коли Росія буде в
Україні це буде Росія
не створила нічого такого щоб я хотів
жити там Якби вона створила щось небудь
Можливо я би ще вагався і ви не було б
якісь роздуми Росія цього не створила в
той час як в Україні здається цінності
які мені близькі і я би хотів би щоб тут
народилася Моя дитина вийшла на вулицю
гуляти якщо не дай боже хтось-небудь
знайшов з ними зробить то я точно знаю
що в Україні більше можливостей і
інструментів захистити цю дитину ніж в
Росії бо в Росії окрім корупції це ще є
кланові стій ще Куча Куча інших проблем
це просто такий знаєте це такий чиряк на
на планеті які вибухне
і і я думаю я надіюсь що він вибухне
через те що він пішов на Україну
в мене немає оце відчуття знаєте такого
щоб я щиро виклав і сказав ідентифікував
так що я хочу вбивати російських
військових в мене є Відчуття того що
хочеться щоб
ну ви знаєте уявляєте собі що біжить там
багато-багато собак
по життю я собак дуже люблю я не хочу їх
вмивати в мене немає сенсу це робити
коли ця НАТО в собак біжить я ти бачиш
перш ніж добіжить вона до тебе Вона
біжить до дітей до жінок до Бабусь ти
розумієш що вбивати їх це правильно дія
правильна дія оскільки це зупинить біль
цих дітей які вони не можуть самі себе
захистити з точки зору саме мотиву бути
на вільний мотив зупинити
вбивство цивільних наших військових і
зупинити Росію цей мотифія мотив
вибивати росіян немає їх не в моєму
житті їх не існує Я б не хотів би щоб
вони існували і в майбутньому в моєму
житті навколо мене знаєте десь нехай
десь заб'ються собівалясті і там сидять
прекрасне місце і їм буде краще і нам
вони це будуть відчувати відчувати себе
безпеці і ми будемо дуже щасливі тому
саме вбивати Росію росіян оце знаєте
щире бажання вбивати росіян тому що ні
немає це дуже сильне відчуття ненависті
яке ви знаєте Я б не хотів подарувати їм
Краще б я подарував би з такою силою
любов своїм близьким і був би
ефективнішим якби і без емоційно просто
зупиняв би цих росіян ви не мали
перечуття там що все ж не так думаєш
можливо буде тільки ескалація на сході
мені було цілком Логічно що буде велика
війна
Питання в тому коли вона буде в який
момент в якому вигляді вона буде Я не
володів такою інформацією скручу чесно
після димовулізації Я б не хотів Я не
хотів взагалі згадувати про армію
тому що ви знаєте мені війни вистачило
Що з дитинства ми були в Афганістані
коли війна була війна вона мене ніяк не
затягує знаєте це ті чоловічі ігри які
мені ніколи
не збуджували тобто для мене війна сама
по собі піти воювати стріляти вбивати ну
це звучить гарно і москаліно але ж
Вибачте це не моє Ну я Я розумію що це
коли ти будеш по вулиці
б'є зрозуміло що ти маєш на його напасти
і зупинити
але питання саме в тому що це
конструктивно різні речі Одна справа ти
захищаєш ні справа коли Ти нападаєш але
я так розумію на 24-го ви прямо пішли
військома так числа вже не поїхав нікуди
я вже вирішив що я тут буду ми тут були
з одним підрозділом
виконували певні задачі із Києва вже не
їхав весь цей час
вже колись з Києва ну зрозуміло було що
немає загрози Києва що захопити Київ Я
вже зрозумів що мені треба йти в
регулярну армію це
те місце де Мені буде зручно комфортно
де я буду все відчувати ефективним
оскільки коли в тебе немає родинної в
тебе руки ноги і навіть два ока то в
принципі Логічно що ти маєш піти воювати
Якщо в тебе є досвід бо якщо в тебе є
мотивація бо якщо в тебе немає мотивації
чи досвіду ти можеш там опинитись
проблемою
і я люблю повторяти цю історію що не
можна вимірювати під час війни свої
корисність кількістю власних страждань
бо тому що для того щоб ви страждаєте
Україна не переможе це не є це так не
працює
яким чином що ви задаєте питання в чому
найкраще можете робити і робите те що
для перемоги потрібно Тобто ви вважаєте
ви казали вже Що Не всі чоловіки мають
йти там впливати Я вважаю що
Я вважаю що Не всі чоловіки На війні є
ефективними і потрібні там
сама країна не зупинилась вся країна
працює
ви знаєте що щоб забезпечити місто типу
Києва
просто їжею треба сотні
десятків
вирішення тисячі фур продовольця
привозити сюди і вивозити звідси сміття
це все працює все що якщо забрати звідти
всіх чоловіків що ми захищаємо тоді
цивільні люди помирають від зрошу
нестачі їжі води інфраструктура і так
далі Тому треба зробити у нас над
задачами зберегти Україну яка працює і
Захистити її
і це робиться чоловіками як кіно що
воюють так і тими хто працює
тому дуже важливо собі чітко відповідати
на питання Де я ефективний в цій війні
бо Звісно що простіше за все Як я зробив
собі в армію для мене Це було б дуже
просто ви не був досвід в мене є
обов'язок не піти в армію це дивно І це
було легко насправді Це правильне
рішення але якби в мене не було
військового воєнного досвіду бойового
досвіду Я думаю що мені треба 300 тисяч
разів подумати чи я потрібен туди чому
мені потрібно туди йти І якщо в мене є
мотив тобто я розумію Нащо Я туди йду не
вимагати від держави щось А захищати її
тоді треба йти Але якщо я знаю що я
зараз працюю водієм фури
то я розумію що я для держав в цілому
корисний там А як ви тоді ставитесь до
того що роздають повістки як покарання
своєрідне
це принижує тих хто пішов воювати хто
воює це така недолугість
Я думаю що це ви знаєте від чого це по
Фрейду у них от тих хто роздається
повістки вони такі Ну вони б самі не
пішли бо воювати для них це є Ну
Деструктивна історія вона є для них
незрозуміла вони би краще втекли від
призову тому вони маючи такий патерну
поведінки свій ну своїй голові вони
вважають що для всіх інших Це теж є
покаранням але це не так для мене
наприклад
Якби я знав що порозі мною хлопець який
там був на пляжі і займався сексом з
кимось А йому там дала повістка він тут
зупинився я би
Я не знаю про що мені з ним говорити Як
це і все ми Головне що я не зможу йому
пояснити чому я тут і чому наприклад
мені дико що він дивиться Шарій Я
наприклад ну це це якось незрозуміло
Питання в тому щоби люди в армії були
ефективними і давайте я зараз скажу
можливо дуже дику річ але
людина в армії це ресурс Вона може
захищати Вона може працювати бути
ефективною коли є вбивають чи ранять
це витрати держави так само як і навчити
цю людину в університеті в школі
спочатку в університеті це
медицина і так далі це витрати держави
на цю людину а потім взяти її запустити
туди куди вона не є ефективним просто її
вбивають це дуже дуже
Вибачте що це я ж кажу що за цю цинізм
якщо їм людей не жалко то це питання
ресурсів
це гроші сказали що ви підірвались на не
російські міні чи це можна назвати
своєрідним Фредді фаєр
так в принципі можна сказати я дуже хочу
дочекатись результату пока скажуть що
насправді там відбулось Бо для мене це
важливо просто знати хоча знаєте
це не зробить мені другий око
це не зробить мого іншого побратима
живим а ще іншого більш здоровим але це
для того щоб не повторювати помилок
бо ми всі ці 7-8 тижнів могли бути
ефективними на війні ефективно вибивати
російських військових аби зупинити їх
наступну Україну ефективно це робити ми
могли ми були супермотовані є розумію що
я би Не хотів би щоб ці помити
повторялось
треба дуже зрозуміти що зараз під час
війни в нас зв'язані руки в сенсі того
щоб критикувати
військове керівництво я би і не хотів це
робити тому що це робить нас ще
слабкішим Але я хочу щоб ці роботи
помилками вже зараз відбувалися
це шлях до перемоги Тому що ті помилки
які робить Росія Дай Боже щоб вона
робила Ще більше їх
нам дуже повезло з таким
ідіотом ворогом
але ми маємо бути ще розумнішим і це
можливо тільки аналізуючи помилки і
роблячи правильні виставки тому з цих
підстав Я думаю що треба про це говорити
саме Так ви казали що це можливо була
проблема комунікації між підрозділами Це
була проблема комунікації ви розумієте
що карта мінних полів вона
дуже важлива
оскільки коли ви наступаєте ви маєте
знати де там він мені не залишили так
само як і ви відступаєте ви ставите ці
зміни і важливо для чого Тому що коли ми
йдемо типу Херсону забирати своє
будемо менше втрат наших коли ми знаємо
ці карти мильних полів вони Я розумію що
росіяни будуть ставити міни але питання
того щоби мені не
були щоб карти мене полів була це дуже
важливо Це треба зробити на цьому акцент
ви знаєте як ми робимо акцент на якихось
речах які ми там це про якість війни і
ми маючи меншу людей ресурсів ніж
росіяни мають бути сотні разів якіснішою
А ви сказали що карти мідних полів її
немає чи вона просто не неграмотно
заповнюється чи в чому вона просто ви
знаєте
скажімо
в цій частині потрібно більше дисципліни
коли це є прям обов'язково
коли на цьому роблять акценти командири
і це є знаєте На цьому фокусують
командуючі і кажуть що Дивіться це
важливо коли про це так будуть коли
будуть робити саме таким чином я думаю
що ситуація зміниться тому що ви знаєте
Перше про що я подумав Коли я прийшов до
тями Це де моя зброя бо я знаю що за неї
за відсутність цієї зброї буде
відповідальність
так само з картами мільних полів це дуже
важливо Це про життя якщо не зрозуміло
там Деяким людям оце прямо на скільки це
дорівнює життя То ти поставив міно це
дорівнює або 15 мільйонів якщо вмерла
людина або декілька 15 мільйонів тих щоб
можна багато людей Питання в тому що це
мій не має бути
якщо вона поставлена ці карти мають бути
зазначені ця обмінність цієї інформації
має бути таким чином ми просто збережемо
своїх людей і швидше переможемо в нас в
Україні на відміну від росіян просто
знаєте прірва наскільки ми любимо людей
і цінному життя наскільки вони їх не
люблять І не цінують але ви знаєте в нас
пішли воювати
дуже здорові люди от ми з найкращих
ще більш кращі люди Вони думають що
підуть полювати наступним наступним
хвилю мобілізації Вона думає що буде
і росіяни пішли воювати хто там пішов
воювати Вибачте це люди які або не мають
грошей тому вони пішли воювати або в них
немає розуму що в принципі зрозуміло
Чому в них немає грошей то власне
відбувається така історія і
На мою думку
питання збереження людей це одне з
ключових питань які зараз є має бути в
державі тому що я ж кажу нас мало нас
набагато менше ніж росіян навіть якщо ви
зараз друге третя Хвильового мобілізації
ми вибираємо людей кадри які можуть
створювати
іт-компанії які можна створювати ті
компанії які допомагають Україні стати
іншою на міжнародній арені і ну
здобувати якихось плюси це це і
спортсмени це і в доктора це і лікарі ну
це дуже круті люди які можуть вивести
Україну в якісну інший рівень
вони зараз помирають де не збігався
написав пост про недоліки комунікації
які ви репостнули і Денис пояснив що він
вважає слабкими місцями в плані
комунікації в нашій армії А що ви
вважаєте ви знаєте Я думаю що в першу
чергу треба прибрати
певну конкуренцію між
підрозділами вона
є І вона не є вона не є принциповою
такою що Знаєте от але про одне просто є
на рівні підсвідомості і обмін певними
даними має бути
захищений в першу чергу але він має бути
ця інформація має відбуватися тому що це
розвіддані ця інформація яка може
вберегти нас від
втрат можуть допомогти нам
швидше зупиняти росіян і це це саме
працює історію а ви сказали що вам дуже
допомогла психологі
допомога і
в загальному без деталей але це
стосувалось травми чи загалом вашого
досвіду на
зоні Я би хотів би щоб психологи
працювали з військовими до того як вони
пораняться бо це про ефективність в тому
числі як вони воюють з яким мотивом вони
воюють що їх турбує як вони розуміють цю
систему заради чого вони воюють
Бо коли ви маєте мотив і Він достатньо
сильний воно дає вам більше сил ви
можете більше вижити
більш гірших в гірших умовах перебувати
і при цьому не зволікати на ці умови
і психолог мені допомогла Вона пояснила
про певні речі пов'язані з втратою я їх
не ідентифікував тому що ви знаєте в
мене не було нікого такої втрати
здоров'я
але вона допомогла із цим почуттями
провини які я зараз у кожної людини і ви
розумієте що коли її почуття провини в
мене наприклад моїм другом Що я живіший
Я розумію що з цими маю щось зробити бо
це ну це дискомфортне почуття провини і
ти маєш зробити щось небудь і От тепер
питання ти це робиш за нащо якась який
яка мета твоїх дій щоб вгамувати свої
почуття дискомфорту чи щось зробити йому
щось гарне бо це може бути суттєвий
різні речі бо те що потрібно Мені треба
для галочки або щось зробити якщо
начебто допомогти йому але йому це не
допоможе
тому ідентифікувати такі почуття
розуміти їх що з тобою відбувається і
потім вчиняти крок який можуть вгамувати
то біль дуже важливі це розуміння це
інструкція по використанню
психіки людини Я вважаю що
цього дуже не вистачає в армії і це
зробило нас якісно іншому ви сказали що
в нас великий трав втрати які причини на
вашу думку цього в першу чергу тому що в
нас немає
артилеріїв такі кількості в якій ми
могли би вести цю війну розумієте що як
війна відбувається і піхота є артилерія
артилері б'є далеко коли у вас немає
артилерії щоб зупинити
росіян піхота має підійти ближче або як
діяти якщо ви не можете зупинити їх
артерію
Таким чином коли ви підходите ближче
арта ще більше б'є в них є безліч
зарядів є дуже багато установок і саме
тому в нас великий втрати в них теж дуже
великі втрата через те що в них
логістики є проблеми зі стратегією
проблемами але вони достатньо розумні
росіяни
і
мені здається що в першу чергу питання
саме в озброєнні була в нас іншого
збройні була би в рази менше втрата Якщо
говорити про Мирне життя
колишній агенпрокурорка вже колишня
Ірина венедиктова вас з нею була
взаємодія з вами це так ви навіть
влаштовували в 20-му році мітинг під
назвою татарова за ґрати ви недитеві
відставку Здається так тепер вона
звільнена але скоріш за все її
призначать посолкою Швейцарії Як ви до
цього ставитесь
ви знаєте я до вендитової ставлюсь
крайні негативно
її речі які вона зробила Вони для мене
досі щось під великим знаком питання
і це не тому що я
думаю що всі про це знають що я особисто
ненавиджу ворог для мене він є номер
один один з перших хто це Порошенко який
фактично зробив дуже багато
поганих речей які ми не можемо вибачити
просто на рівні того що в нього була
можливість вирішити це питання я візьму
елементарні речі там прокатю Гандзюк да
тобто була можливість бути людиною
не люблю не тому що я там не знаю там я
якось за Порошенка або проти Зеленського
Ні вони того просто вона мені для мене
зрозуміло Чому вона йшов
який в неї є плюс
якщо ми розуміємо що там для неї або там
для тих хто ставить якусь важливим є
момент довіри наприклад і слухняності
все мені цілком зрозуміло
є Довіра вона слухняна хоча дуже велике
питання чи вона
зраджувала тому самому зеленському в
своїх справах і це було видно як ці
справи були і вашим і нашим але це не їх
нехай совісті будуть тому для мене
диктували те що вона пішла Це добре але
я не впевнений що це стане краще Питання
в тому що
чому саме цей генпрокурор який в нього
взагалі яке в нього бачення майбутнього
України Я не знаю Для мене це важливо
тому що я кажу що я хочу повертатись в
Україну хочу тут залишатись і щоб тут
мої діти виходили на вулиці і відчували
себе в безпеці в взаємодії з державою
коли злочинці якісь будуть заходити в
генпрокуратуру закривати якісь справи Я
хочу бути впевнений що у цієї людини яка
прийшла в генпрокуратуру цінності такі
самі як об тому захищаємо одне й те саме
роки без питань А зараз ви знаєте себе
дуже неправильна історія по відношенню
до народу це дерево комунікувати Я
вважаю що чому саме цей генпрокурор
треба комунікувати не можна просто
призначити його і вважати що там натовх
Людей просто воюють собі нехай там
займатися Це не їх сивача справа ні так
не працює ми люди
ми Влада в цій країні і ми маємо право
знати чому цей генпрокурор ви здається в
інтерв'ю УП першому своєму сказали що
пише щодня книгу Коли були в зоні
бойових дій зрозуміло що ця книга буде
про війну але про що саме яка тема для
мене більше було важливо продати
оці внутрішні переживання на війні
оскільки ви знаєте що зараз теж
через дії росіян
багато хто каже про те що ми маємо там
щось робити не так нелюдно з
військовополонами але ми маємо
усвідомити зараз що такі дії росіян не
мають віддзеркалюватись в нас тому що
коли росіянин говорить російською мовою
в Україні Ми ж не переходимо в російську
мову ні чому Тому що це не Наша Мова це
не наша культурна цінність наш культура
цінність в українській мові так само і в
діях якщо вони так вчиняють вони не
мають своїм прикладом
задавати нам температурам життя
змінювати наші цінності ми в цьому і
більш сильніша нація ніж вони тому що
вони через емоцію можуть дозволити собі
все що завгодно Ми через емоцію
розуміємо що Окей є межа вже в
цивілізованих підходах війни і ця може
не можна перетинати і це розмова саме з
самим собою про такі речі оскільки я їх
не знаю де і про них говорити з ким про
них говорити бо тому що в папі я зараз
не сиджу коли буде сидіти в бабі як буде
в останню про що думати про війну на
вашу думку є якісь речі які Україна вже
зрозуміла А Європа ні так мені здається
що Ми зрозуміли що Росія не зупиниться
на тому що вона захопить Україну
Мені здається що Європа Європа знаєте
вона в якій стані Мені здається що вона
в стані такому коли вона цим налякана і
вона в стані кого вона нічого не робить
Ну дробить але замало
і цей страх зрозумілий мені цей прохолод
взимку це є про подорожчання цін але це
не про те що вони і не дай боже їх діти
будуть йти воювати Я думаю що коли воно
стидомлять що зараз ми віддаємо своїх
людей своїх близьких друзів Ми плачемо
щодня коли бачимо хтось поранений хтось
в лікарні це ми віддаємо
це їм треба усвідомити дуже сильно гарно
собі красиво уявити що може статись Якщо
там будуть обстріли в їх не дай боже
містах в їх культурних спадщинах будуть
будуть поламані ці історії сотні тисяч
років і якщо
ми це розуміємо на своєму власному
досвіді їм достатньо просто відкрити
наші новини подивитись на це і зрозуміти
що Росія ніколи за свої слова не
відповідала
і тому
я розумію що наслідки нашого програшу це
війна в Європі